sean is in pittsburgh hey sean how are
you
hi dave thank you so much for taking my
call sure how can we help
so four years ago my wife and i bought a
house in
colorado that turned out to be a big
mistake because we couldn't afford it we
bought too much house
and we ended up selling it two years
later made about 30 grand profit off of
it used it to sell
to get rid of all the debt we had and we
moved out to west virginia
where i got a job as a youth pastor and
now that job has kind of
ended and we're looking at moving back
to colorado and i was wanting to ask you
if it would be a good
idea um our plan here we're thinking
about moving in with my parents that
live right next to
uh where we work in colorado remotely
right now
we're thinking about moving in with my
parents and living their rent free
to save up a bunch of money for a little
while and then buying a lot of land
and then using that land as collateral
to get a loan to build
a house instead of buy one outright
because of the market out there the
houses are so expensive we're like well
we could probably
save a bunch of money and have tons of
equity in the house already if we just
built one instead of buy one
so sean let me ask you a couple of
questions before dave jumps in here
uh you said you're working remotely so
are you no longer pastoring and
are you doing you're doing something
else
yeah so uh the the youth pastoring job i
have here is
um i feel like god's calling me on just
other things in colorado
to move back there and so i put in my
notice that i'll be leaving
in july when my lease is up at our
apartment here in west virginia and
we're going to be moving back to
colorado
and what will you be doing and how much
money will you all be making a year
so um i will be pursuing a new job to
like make more income but right now
what we will be making my wife and i
together will be about
um 60 to 65 a year
okay cool so here's my answer real quick
before we go to our commercial break
uh no i don't want you to go back in
with your parents and i and i don't even
want you to get a piece of land
right now you need to go ahead and just
get a solid foundation
i would go rent an apartment and then
follow the baby steps from there because
it sounds like you don't have three
months in your emergency fund already
correct
yeah yeah so get an apartment live below
your means
and go in the heck you said you paid off
all your debt get your three to six
months set aside
then you and your wife can start looking
at land down the road
we don't need to move into your parents
house skip over baby set three to go buy
a house you're gonna be right back in
the situation you are today
so get an apartment get three months and
you'll be straight
yeah that's exactly right the um the
idea of buying a piece of land and
building a house and having a bunch of
instant equity
is not it's not going to work out that
way um when you finish building a house
you're going to have
almost in it what you would have had had
you bought a house
that's what it costs to build a house
and so
you don't get like a 50 discount because
you built from the ground up it doesn't
work that way
so no i think you i think anthony's
right you need to get a little apartment
get your jobs and your careers
solidified and then start
gradually working your way back into
home ownership at that point
that's going to be your best bet